so you know Elton John pretty well well
so Elton's husband David and I went to
high school together
random 400 years ago in Toronto and
we've stayed friends and so we've got to
well I mean there was a crazy time when
we first reconnected as well and grace
was just starting where I actually said
to my wife I think Elton and David are
coming over for dinner
she freaked out she freaked out I
freaked out but logic set in and we
barbecued I was what do you serve Sir
Elton John yes pretty much anything he's
nothing but I can roll with that all
right but what was I always tell the
story because it's we had a new piano at
the time and I was just learning to play
and it's the four of us and my son who's
six months old and I I got up the nerve
I said Elton you know you have to
christen the piano Elton John christened
your piano so he goes just down the
street and he goes he sits down and he
says what would you like me to play and
I'm so at this moment I still want him
to know me and know that I am a big fan
so I'm not gonna say Rocket Man no so
obviously I said I've seen that movie
too from goodbye yellow brick road and
he looked up at me and says oh bugger
off I don't remember that song you were
trying to be cool boy yeah I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
YouTube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this